é o apl óóó o ato de pessoal aqui quem
fala é o dar que sejam muito bem vindos
é mais um mais um filho e eu gostava
jack casa do cansado de olhar tudo está
tudo bem
antes de passarmos o vídeo eu quero
dizer que nós estamos quase a atingir a
meta de economia 1 milhão de inscritos
olha eu ainda não sei como é que lidar
com esta situação peço a vossa ajuda
vamos chegar mais rápido ao milhão
manuel canal de voz de michael pela
vossa mãe neste canal porque vocês
quiserem eu vou fazer um especial em
breve portanto embora lá pessoal nos dar
um especial do milhão vai ser brutal
lutar tanto ajuda e buscar mais rápido
foi quando você foi quando 22 vão julgar
e ainda achar os illuminati
seu personagem é um ano o seu personagem
do gênero feminino não o seu personagem
é brasileiro também não o sexo frágil
luta eu acho que não é o seu personagem
é real esta é a dúvida que paira no ar e
iluminar que será real ou não ligo
passeios pessoal comentei mas o seu
personagem tem cabelo não seu personagem
tem forma de um animal comia não o seu
personagem usa roupa também não sei quem
é um robô que será que será que o robô
não sai de um paciente que sofre da [ __ ]
que ó seu personagem e ganham e para
quem não sabe o que é um garanhão ganham
é não é fácil enfrentar ganham é é um
homem bonito
a imagem é um beagle raça imagem é
vendido também não o seu personagem
resolve ministérios mistério em versão
resolveu eu não saí iluminante eu não
sei se o sol mas é um mistério também
dizer que sim o seu personagem é mal
iluminada e é mal perguntou você ainda
não saiba é mau é mal iluminada é mau
mesmo seu personagem dando espaço não o
seu personagem tem pernas também não se
o personagem tem mau cheiro
será que o mau cheiro illuminati claque
não até não sei o que está sendo feito
de metal também não o seu estágio tem
mais de 30 anos vem tem mais chance de
ser supostamente os illuminatis nem
cheiram naquela altura lado os pintores
lado de artistas portanto eu acho sim
tem mais 30 anos o personagem tem dois
olhos não só tem um iluminado só
terminou eu acho que a única pessoa
neste mundo que joga aqui na equipe e
sei que estão jogo da ação que propunha
o dem estourou o seu personagem tem mais
de três metros
eu nunca vi um iluminado e à frente né
na verdade nunca ninguém viu não sai
olha aí o atleta já fica furioso seu
personagem é uma figura religiosa
pergunta complicada após também ter que
discutir iluminar que vieram da religião
pois em outros artigos dizem que não têm
nada a ver com moda se você não sonho
seu personagem aparenta ter mais de 30
anos sim o seu personagem insulta raio
illuminati tem superpoderes o iluminado
e eu sou iluminada tinha ainda que um
raio que o personagem está ligada a
esportes nominal foi de se ilumina a
atenção uma imagem com um olho logo não
faz do esporte por não eu acho que a lua
lua ao descobrir uma nova teoria pessoal
do super soal é lua e illuminati
conseguimos ganhar aqui na inter pessoal
eu não conseguiu alinhar com os
illuminati várias de sol esta não contou
porque iluminados são vários personagens
não é só uma personagem claro que
acredito não vai encontrar mãe eu não
vou desistir a eu não vou dizer eu não
vou mais tempo a próxima gestão e do e
pedia que eu diz desencontraram blasina
se espalhasse chega eles o seu
personagem é um miúdo boa não o seu
personagem existe na vida real senão a
que existe os pedacinhos uau claro que
se espalhasse tema do caso e aí eu vou
dizer que sim que existe na vida real o
seu personagem está relacionado ao
futebol na o seu personagem é uma mulher
dam
é não se sabe se o goleiro não tanto
assim mas carné que o palhaço não é
palhaça logo a partir de ser um homem é
portanto o palhaço sendo assim o seu
personagem mora no seu país
eu saiba não segue o personagem vive em
portugal canadá e outra vez aqui dentro
as consultas com o seu personagem já fez
um filme pornô
será que o caso já seja aviação e isto
não o seu personagem tem irmão os
palhaços inchou muito alta no país
platino sem irmãos
acho que não né o seu personagem é loiro
aluna não sai também o sim muitas coisas
o seu personagem já foi o seu país a
execução é igual falhasse nós estamos a
falar em que já faleceu em que não
favoreceu o que ainda está vivo por aí
toma disso as ruas e tudo mundo será não
sei o seu estágio é famoso por cantar
não se o personagem vanda internet esta
é uma pergunta também relativamente um
pouco complicado responder já repararam
que agora tudo escolas que vão por cento
é só em outubro de cassação já para já
treinaram em estudo espalhados vender
netbooks ou youtube você consegue ver os
pela senhora ultimamente uma pessoa
qualquer sai de casa e não ver palhaço
não tiver uma câmera foi em outubro
saber palhaço em tua graça em tudo lá o
seu personagem usa vestido azul não nos
investimentos naquela roupa do paraná o
seu personagem é um programa de
computador e que não sabe estarem já
transou com você
ai meu deus ana não não não o seu
personagem é uma boa pessoa não na net
póstumo para a festa assim não é nada
assim é bom o seu personagem é mau
a caneta é a partir do momento em que
algo não é bom nem mau
logo à partida não precisa perguntar
quem é o seu personagem possui um cabelo
quem nunca viu o crespo sim eu acho que
isso é crespo lenta
ae sinto um crespo seu personagem tem um
lado negro sim o seu personagem tem um
piloto mas o santa mas o santos é
natalia só saio toda olha se espalhasse
ó eu acho que a possibilidade por um
eventual um bíblico mas não vou dizer
que não saiu seu personagem tem muitas
tatuagens também não não fosse o seu
personagem toca flauta o seu personagem
é muito misterioso sim o personagem usa
aparelho não o seu personagem é tua em
algum filme de grande sucesso não só
lilith o personagem bíblico pessoal hoje
vocês são muito bons nisso os você hoje
nós estamos que enganar o atleta eu já
fui o iluminado e já foi um palácio
assine
vamos pra próxima próxima sugestão é do
um minuto os humanos deixaram 30 mil só
que esta vai ser complicado vamos lá ver
se isto tem um furdunço o que não é o
seu personagem tem um canal de jogos não
só personagem é do gênero feminino fosse
classe mx1 desmarcações foi não é
novidade
ok o seu personagem neste ano mesmo que
você não é do brasil o seu estágio luta
o seu personagem é real estéreo pessoal
estéreo o mistério fica no ar o grande
mistério está aqui é real ou será que
apenas um pronúncio não sabia o seu
personagem faz parte de uma série de tv
não substituem é do banho
acho que sim eu só se limita a espalhar
a informação o seu personagem tem mais
de mil e nos canais o seu personagem é
de um filme também não o seu personagem
vive da música não fosse o personagem
está ligado a esporte também eu tenho
mais de 30 é não o seu personagem é de
um jogo não o seu personagem é uma
criança não se o personagem tem forma de
um animal assim seu estágio é o youtube
e já falou direto e n marley outubro ela
é e subtraem escritor não se o
personagem é uma faca na bolsa
crone chun uma coisa se eu tocar nela o
seu personagem é uma raposa sim
el finalmente eu tenho uma pessoal
encontrou flávio tenius grande
influência em e também é notícia daqui
frame contra o flu fino aqui nem ter mt
o dedo no google e na próxima gestão é
do nic gamer br nic.br ninguém mais
perto de fazer o atleta fim a um jorge
china eu já tentei encontrar tanta
personagem que já nem ambos já procura
de um cinema eu acho que não tentamos
procurar buchichio por acaso já procurei
de gama e nos comentários
vamos lá mas o personagem é o dunga não
o seu personagem tem mais 25 anos sim o
seu personagem te conhece não eu sempre
fazem é brasileiro [ __ ] [ __ ] e etah
moleque o paçoca ou shopping apaixonam o
seu personagem está continuando o
futebol não o seu personagem é uma
mulher não seu personagem é português
seu personagem é real se seu personagem
é um ator tecnicamente sim né porque o
resto eu não sei se vocês sabem o tipo
resto ninguém aqui é tudo quanto já da
nec vai tudo
xuxa e deixou um sotaque é ensinado nem
portanto vou dizer que é um ator sem o
seu personagem faz parte de uma série de
tv e sim o personagem é um ato com ele e
não o seu estágio multa contra os zumbis
o seu personagem participa de campanhas
d'aires não suportarem é parte da série
subiu na tosca não se o personagem lutas
em é uma luta que o personagem é que
enfim o gol também nasceu personagem tem
um filho com seu personagem faz parte da
banda ou el mocito jaó torcida que nos
apoiou de uma piscina o odeon
assim o seu personagem usa boné que
usava nem assim o seu personagem os
laços brancos no cabelo
o laço branco não sei não faço ideia o
secretário faz parte do lote de inflexão
reportagem ataca pessoas
mas eles mas não né
então é isso ao justificar porque o
estúdio já sabem comentei aqui embaixo
mais personagens para tentar encontrar
aqui não acreditar nesse episódio falei
duas que existem mais duas por tanques
que foi 50 e 51 mas é isso pessoal
quanto com o semelhante já sabem deixem
o vosso mega lá que fica à espera deste
mundial espera do ir embora já deixaram
80 ainda tem a certeza já deixou sua
marca pessoal este era o tempo pra vocês
deixaram o vosso lycra e outra coisa
pessoal vão perceber algumas coisas e
agora meu lado e aqui em cima aqui neste
cantinho pai por ser uma bolinha quando
vocês podem inscrever é grátis pessoal
prometem marcar agora ser pessoal muito
obrigado por tudo foi fácil está
enganado e é isso mas no próximo
episódio é é um outro avião